there are plenty of reasons we are told
to hate
america today america is racist
sexist homophobic trans
all sorts of phobias and various things
we're told but there's a new one on the
list
and you might not have heard about it
yet my producer has been getting a lot
of these videos he wants me to react
to the new great scourge affecting
america
fat phobia yes this video is sponsored
by acre gold acre
the new easier more affordable way to
buy gold more from them in a minute
first
let's take the fat phobia face on
hey bestie oh gosh you're wrong
i think it's time for another adult
pre-k lesson what do you think
all right why do they all talk like this
catch a bubble in your mouth
good job okay here's the thing catch
your balls
having a preference is something like
i'm looking for a partner who likes
kayaking
or wakes up early in the morning or
loves pizza
but when your preferences exclude an
entire group of marginalized people
that's problematic
okay that's not nice that's not a
preference if you lump all
fat people in one group together as
though they are not
very different individuals that's fat
phobic
just like lumping all black people in
one group and saying i don't like black
people
is racist i'm lumping all disabled
people in one group and saying
i don't think people in wheelchairs are
hot is ableist
do you understand what i'm saying so why
do they always do that creepy like
giggly
you know really entitled all of the left
not i'm not saying all the fat people
who you who you calling those people
what do you mean you people
no i'm not referring to fat people i'm
saying all the radical leftists do that
sort of thing it's just that giggle ha
ha
very intense her claim of course is that
if you're not attracted
to fat people that you're a bigot if
you're not attracted to any group
then your preference ceases to be a
preference
now i don't quite understand that
illogic there it would still be a
preference it's just a preference she
doesn't like
but what if i say look i'm a man i
identify as super straight that's a new
sexual
identity and i'm not attracted to other
men by her definition i'm
i'm now a bigot in a way i guess i am a
bigot i knew it
i am closed-minded in as much as i'm
excluding some people from my
preferences
but but let's take it further because
she compares it to race and she says
it's racist you know if you're
not attracted to every single race if a
japanese guy
wants to marry a japanese girl right
he's he's more attracted to japanese
girls than he is to say
nigerian girls or scandinavian girls
is he a racist for that i don't think
that's racist
if a jew wants to marry another jew is
that racist that's you know you always
hear that the jewish mother always wants
to make sure her daughter marries a nice
jewish boy is that racist
i guess in it like in a way yeah sort of
but is it
is there something wrong about that for
for people to feel attraction to certain
groups and
not to other groups i don't think so but
the the radical
liberation of this ideology you know
that you see in
radical feminism radical uh sexual
revolution stuff you know lgbt
radical this radical that demands that
we be open
to everything and not not have any
preferences ironically she's saying
she's denying my lived experience she's
saying if if you have this preference
then then you're
you're some sort of bigot not very
persuasive
even even if we all catch a bubble in
our mouth and listen uh
not very convincing next one for the
millionth time body positivity is not a
movement about health
so when you bring health into it you are
being fat phobic
the body positive movement was created
by fat black women in the sixties
to one create a safe space for fat
people
to address systemic fat phobia and fat
depression
because nine times out of ten fat people
are not treated like people
in 95 percent of situations and it was
also created to challenge oh good light
society's unrealistic beauty standards
and to showcase that beauty is not
dictated by your size
guess what none of those things have to
do with health
so when you bring health into a movement
that is not about health
ring-a-ding-ding that's fat phobia so
[ __ ] cut it out
this is the worst example of when you
put a
vertical video on on a screen and then
they put the thing it looks like
like multiple of this woman are just
screaming at me every second
it's fat phobia she says to
suggest that maybe people be healthy she
says the fat
acceptance movement the body positivity
movement is not about health like
ding ding ding you're right it's not
about health but it ought to be you know
we ought to be able to say
that it's not good if you're too skinny
we would call that anorexic and say you
gotta beef up a little bit
and if you're extremely overweight then
you know it's not the end of the world
you're going to do what you're going to
do but it might be good
to get into a healthier position but
we're not allowed to have standards at
all
right forget about she's just focusing
on standards of beauty but we're not
even
allowed to have standards of health
we're not allowed to say that one thing
is healthier than another thing
we're not allowed to say that one thing
looks better than another thing
the standards have to go away according
to the left because for the left
everything is is for the extreme left i
should say
everything is just a product of social
construction so if you can redefine the
words
you can redefine reality itself and
this woman is very upset because no
matter how much we redefine all of our
words
these physical realities continue to
exist
and they don't like that very much you
know speaking of physical things
it's a great idea to invest in physical
gold if you want to hedge
your investments i know what you're
thinking you're going to say michael
physical gold is expensive
what if i told you you can get started
investing in it for thirty dollars
thirty dollars michael you liar no
thirty dollars a month acre has figured
out this ingenious way
to subscribe to gold bars for as little
as thirty dollars a month
you pay each month once your gold stash
reaches the price of their gold bars
they will discreetly ship acre gold to
your house they've got a new 100
a month subscription to a 5 gram gold
bar it's fabulous
they will let you invest in physical
gold without coming out of pocket ball
at once and then
you know once your gold stash reaches
their gold bars you'll get it it's where
you've got it in your possession
i've really enjoyed investing in
precious metals really nice way to hedge
against all the kind of craziness that
we're seeing
around the world and we're actually
seeing right now at this very second so
head on over to getacregoal.com
start investing in physical gold today
make sure you go to that url because
acres giving away a gold bar to qualify
for the giveaway
tweet or post while you should be the
recipient and mention at get underscore
acre that's getacregold.com
knowles thank you aker gold for
supporting the show
back to the fat phobia i don't know if
this qualifies for no nuance november
but it's a point i really want to make
tick-tock fat phobes edition now while
individuals such as myself having
confidence in the people we are and the
bodies we inhabit
is not a proven contributor to obesity
in fact it's shown that self-confidence
can help you make more positive
behavioral changes
fat shaming on the other hand and yes
this includes health shaming
especially that of children and
adolescents is proven to cause further
weight gain
and yes is recognized as a contributor
to obesity
what i'm getting to you tiresome trolls
is that you
in fact are the ones promoting obesity
oh damn facts is spicy this is a really
confusing one because there's this lady
who's
who's making the fat phobia points and
then there's another lady who's like
cheering her on in the side of the
video and i didn't know if she was being
ironic or something her argument here is
a little different than the other one
the other ladies are saying it's really
good to be super fat that's like awesome
and there's nothing wrong with that
this lady is saying it's wrong for you
to say it's wrong to be super fat
because you'll encourage people to be
super fat
which is wrong do you see how perverse
that logic
is because i at least i get the argument
the main fat phobia argument is
no standards whatsoever don't you dare
tell anyone that they should put down
the cupcake
the new version that this lady is
putting out there is
if you tell someone to put down the
cupcake they won't and that's bad
because people should put down the
cupcake so this one's actually making
the kind of conservative point
but she's she's using this weird logic
of saying if you encourage people to
lose weight they won't do it
you need to use reverse psychology or
something it's very similar to the
people who say
you know if you want abortion to rates
to go down you need to have a lot of
legal abortion and then actually during
when there's a lot of legal abortion
people have fewer abortions which is
just not true
but also it's it's a kind of you're
giving away the game and you're saying
yeah
abortion is bad we should have less of
it and you're you're just
kind of trying to agree with the the
basic argument of conservatives to
advocate for your policy well
that's what this lady is doing here this
is much less persuasive than the other
gals before okay
next up weight loss is a privilege
because it takes time and it takes money
which not everybody has access to
now do most people have the time to fit
some kind of exercise into their day yes
it doesn't take long to go on a quick
walk and when i was a server i walk
all day at work but in some instances if
you are very low income
it can be very hard to lose weight and
here's why you work maybe three or four
jobs on your way home you don't have
time to cook so you pick up fast food
and once you get home you have to attend
to your five children and all the money
that you made during that day has to go
to them so you have no time to go on a
walk no money to get a gym membership
and you have to resort to fast food
because that's all you can have time for
so if you really care about the health
of fat people like you say that you do
here's some things that you can advocate
for
healthier options at fast food
restaurants giving public access to gym
spaces for
free cheaper greener options and
advocate for less discrimination for fat
people in the workplace because we make
less money than thin people and no not
everybody can use the excuse not enough
time or money as to why they're not
losing weight
but what you need to understand is i
don't owe you an excuse in exchange for
my existence
nor do i owe you any kind of weight loss
so if i am happy being fat
i can be because fat people aren't just
failed thin people yeah she seems really
happy right
she obviously this woman's very happy
just like all these radicals very very
happy no probably not she says you need
fancy gym membership
to lose weight you need you know a
delivery service from whole foods
no you don't no you don't what you do
need is discipline
and that's hard and there are different
points in people's lives and they've got
more discipline or less discipline but
did you know how you lose weight
you just eat less that's how how dare
you no i'm not saying
that you must lose weight i'm not saying
that you can't be husky i'm not saying
that you but if you want to do that she
seems
she's saying it's a good thing to lose
weight she's saying we need to support
obese people to lose weight and we need
to do that by
you know paying for them to have free
gym memberships and go to whole foods or
whatever but
she's acknowledging this would be a
better thing so that's her point it's
not my point
she's saying it's good to lose weight
well if you want to lose weight
you don't need all that fancy stuff you
can just
eat less that's it simple enough that's
a very phobic thing that i just said
what's the next one fat shaming and
skinny shaming are the same
actually no they're not fat people are
denied jobs proper medical care
health insurance they're paid less they
don't have equal access to clothing
travel many public spaces even the body
mass index the way that it discriminates
against women especially women of color
it was created for and based around
white men like phaphobia is literally
rooted in anti-blackness it's rooted in
racism and sexism skinny shaming is not
how many times have you seen marketing
campaigns that are labeled get fat quick
finally add those stubborn 30 pounds
show me where all the weight gain
industries are show me all the damaging
messages that say that skinny equals
unworthy life or skinny equals ugly when
is the last time that you've been
penalized financially when an aircraft
seat had to be accommodated to your
smaller body when is the last time
you've walked into a doctor's office and
after they weighed you
stop listening to what you were actually
there for and told you to just gain
weight because it will fix
everything fat people endure all of that
and more skinny people do not face
employment discrimination or medical
discrimination the world was designed
for you eat a burger is just not
comparable to systemic abuse and
oppression
systemic abuse and approach that's what
it all comes down to so everybody's got
to be able to claim some kind of
oppression whether you're fat or whether
you're skinny
and then by the way you know she's
saying the skinny phobia or something i
mean
that is a real if you're anorexic or
bulimic that is a real pro you can be
committed
to a hospital against your will if
you're if you're too thin as
well you should be so you know there are
issues there but it's not oppression
it's not oppression when a lady goes
into the doctor's office and the doctor
says you really have to lose some weight
that's just called medical advice that's
what you're there that's what you're
paying for
but we're told now that to face reality
or to face a truth
is oppressive and hurtful
[Music]
i i guess it's just because people can't
they can't
make sense of their own suffering like
there is suffering i know
that every every one thinks that
straight white men just never suffer
right straight white men man they got it
they're all just like rich uncle penny
bags
and they've never had a problem in their
life but actually everybody suffers
and that's not everybody else's fault
that is
your fault it's a fact of your nature
that you're broken and if you can't
work on that and cultivate virtue and
you know endure it with patience
that's on you that's your problem we're
all doing it and patience is a virtue
believe it or not
and whining and babbling on tick-tock is
not a virtue it's a vice do we have any
more have we gone through the phobias
it's done that's it we've gone through
all the phobias
the most persuasive argument i guess
was either in the first couple
or this last one is the other ones they
got too confused
the other ones they said yeah it's good
to lose weight but it's not good to you
know it's but it's bad to tell me to
lose weight and whatever
but these were were relatively coherent
within their framework one was don't
ever tell me to lose weight it's
terrible
and the other one was i'm suffering i'm
oppressed i'm this i'm that
and that that is the most basic level of
the radical left argument
that you could possibly make and we're
told you know look if people are happy
this way if we're really happy then you
gotta you gotta let us alone okay
where's the hap i don't see the happy
maybe maybe we'll get it next time
remember to post other videos that you
want to see us discuss
on this channel see you next time
[Music]
you